this could well be the rarest plant in
Britain and now for the first time ever
the ghost orchid has bloomed here in the
UK it's a big deal because it hasn't
been seen in bloom in the UK before so
it's something very unusual as it is so
rare and so difficult to get it in the
in Europe so to have it here and to have
it on display and to have it blooming at
the same time it's really something that
God knows when it's going to happen
again so it's it's really something
remarkable the crowds here at Kew
Gardens are just as excited
well think of the Rarity of these plants
on the planet and to have such a rare
Orchid come full bloom here is a miracle
it truly is and that is exciting because
it gives us a lot of Hope for
conservation around the world
the Orchid made a delicate Journey from
Chicago two weeks ago when it was first
hand carried by a member of the
conservation team now they hope that it
would bloom during the Chelsea flower
show which was last week but the flower
has chosen to Blossom in its own time
and is done here at Kew Gardens
experts here call the ghost orchid
Olympus test to measure just how well
our ecosystems are coping we also like
to think about orchids as being the
canary and the coal mine because if
orchids are doing well then it's a sign
of a healthy ecosystem but if orchids
are doing badly it's an early warning
that something's not quite right with
the ecosystem and it's out of balance
and that other plants and animals are
likely to suffer in due course so it's
if you like it's our early warning
system
for now the ghost orchid
remed traction
butts with a life expectancy of just up
to two weeks people have to get in fast
if they want to catch a glimpse Saba
Chowdhury Sky News